для цих пташок які дзьобають зернята тут
біля меморіалу голодомору зернята - це
життя саме життя хочуть позбавити
українців росіяни саме життя вони
позбавили мільйони під час голодомору
жертв якого ми всі пам'ятаємо але вони
не зупинилися вони розпочали
російсько-українську війну ми маємо
десятки тисяч загиблих Війна
продовжується але ми як нація вижили ми
перемогли ми вперше перемогли ми довели
цілому світові що їм не вдалося задумане
пам'ятаєте Вони хотіли частину українців
по ставити в концентраційні табори
частину виселити в Росію а частину
просто знищити був такий план розділу
українців на категорії і того що саме з
ними хочуть робити росіяни ми перемогли
всі їхні плани так багато українців
виїхало з України але завдяки тому що
вони виїхали ми як нація збереглися і
маємо все зробити щоб наші українці
повернулися сюди на Батьківщину і щоб ми
поперемогли і щоб пам'ять про кожного
загиблих під час голодомору була
збережена